its store vs Gore with the sight of
screaming goats in the 29th MCU movie
Thor love and thunder but how does Jane
Foster play into it how is mule near
back in the picture and what's up with
the man in the mid-credit scene this is
everything you need to know about the
Hard Rock and end of Thor love and
Thunder
to make sense of the ending we have to
go back to the beginning and revisit the
inciting incident that sets both Thor
and Gore the god Butcher on their
oppositional paths to self-discovery and
the emotionally crushing opening scene
of Thor 11 Thunder Gore's daughter dies
of starvation in his arms as he prays to
his God rappu after he buries her rappu
appears to him in an oasis but rather
than reward him for his piety he mocks
him for believing in an eternal reward
this devastating humiliating encounter
drives Gore to renounce his religion
just as the necrosword calls to him with
his family and Faith gone he has nothing
left to lose doubting Gore is a threat
rapu tells him that the necro sword is a
cursed weapon with the power to kill
gods in the comics it's also called all
black and it was forged by God of the
Void null to slice celestials null is
also the comics character who created
the alien symbiotes which spawned goopy
creeps like Venom and Carnage in Thor
love and thunder the necrosword seems to
be a symbiote itself one that draws
power from the vengefulness of its user
until it eventually corrupts and kills
them that's why Gore's appearance
changes when he claims the weapon a
black blood-like substance seeps from
his eyes and mouth and his skin becomes
paler and more marked he initially feels
as though he's been given power which he
has it just comes at a high price Gore
wields the necro sword to butcher his
own God then vows to take down all the
rest to avenge his dead family this is
my vowel
oh God shall die
the weapon doesn't make it through the
movie but since the concept of alien
symbiotes has recently been introduced
into the MCU its backstory and presence
here are still noteworthy
as Thor comes out of his Funk to defend
planets and peoples who suddenly find
themselves without Gods to protect them
he starts to realize that all the
intergalactic unrest is related he
learns that gods are being murdered
Across the Universe and a Gravely
injured Sith warns him that he could be
next sure enough Gore and his black
Berserkers Shadow beasts he conjures
with a necrosword Ambush new Asgard in
the middle of the night Thor Korg King
Valkyrie and Jane Foster as mighty Thor
all show up and fight back but the fight
itself is a distraction Gore and his
minions have rounded up all of new
asgard's children and taken them to the
shadow realm the asgardians think
they've won when the Berserkers Retreat
only when the locals alert the
superheroes that the kids are gone do
they grasp what really happened among
the kidnapped kids is heimdall's son
who's changed his name from Astrid to
Axel in tribute to Guns N Roses front
man Axel Rose Thor tries to help Axel
hone his ability to see throughout space
and time as his father could in effort
to locate them he uses his own shared
Vision to speak to the kids and reassure
them that the adults are coming to
rescue them what Thor can't see at this
point is that Gore is using them as bait
his plan isn't necessarily to harm the
children it's to lure Thor to him and
the God of Thunder whose strength is
rarely matched but who is sometimes
outsmarted is falling for it
one Thor thinks he knows where Gore's
hiding the children he and his team plot
to sneak into omnipotence City and ask
Zeus for an Army in order to defeat the
villain who's sworn to Kill Them All
I come here to raise an army as the
city's festivities begin Our Heroes
sense that the gods might not be so
receptive Thor attempts to persuade Zeus
but the debaucherous and disinterested
Greek God isn't having it publicly he
mocks Thor but privately he whispers
that he doesn't want to cause a panic
and besides they'll be fine as long as
they stay in omnipotence City it's no
skin off Zeus's back if Gore manages to
pick off a few lesser deities he
basically tells Thor to give up his
fight because this God butcher will
never reach eternity this exchange
reveals that while Zeus might have
underestimated Gore he's exactly right
about the villain's plan Gore doesn't
have to slaughter Gods one by one if he
can make it to Eternity the cosmic being
guarded by Godly magic who is
essentially the sentient creation force
of the universe the powerful entity will
grant him one wish he could use that
wish to wipe out the Gods in one breath
Zeus isn't concerned because Gore would
need a key to open the eternity's gate
but just to be safe he intends to keep
Thor and his team as captives since they
know the location of the God's Refuge
Thor appears to kill Zeus with his own
bolt after Korg takes a near-fatal body
destroying hit and they barely escape
with the powerful weapon in tow
while the asgardians Hope Zeus's
lightning bolt in lieu of his army will
help them stop Gore the god butcher is
actually after a different weapon Gore
is baiting Thor so badly because his
battle ax Stormbreaker is of infinitely
more value to him than the God of
Thunder is himself if he can he'll kill
him in combat though if everything goes
according to plan that won't matter what
he really needs is to get to Eternity
and to do that he needs Stormbreaker
confused here's why Stormbreaker is the
key to Gore's plan after the destruction
of mjolnir Thor's old hammer in Thor
Ragnarok the Asgardian needed to forge a
new even more powerful weapon to take on
Thanos in Avengers Infinity War Thor's
second weapon was forged by the dwarf
Eatery and it's enchanted with the power
to summon the bifrost the magical
rainbow bridge as Guardians use to
travel quickly throughout the cosmos
that's a power no other Asgardian weapon
had on its own and Gore figured out that
the ax and its bifrost calling power is
the key he needs to open Eternity his
gate and unlike mjolnir which can only
be lifted by those who are worthy
anybody can pick up and use Stormbreaker
including Gore when the bifrost's beam
fills the rune-like carvings on the
circular door that leads to Eternity
Gore is able to enter and ask for
whatever he wants from The all-powerful
Entity
it's convenient that Jane seems to
manifest in new Asgard Justice Thor
realized she might have been the one who
got away he's as elated to see her as he
is confused however as she's become a
Thor in her own right with mjolnir his
old Hammer which he presumed to be
useless after hella crushed it into
fragments the Romantic tension between
Jane and Thor is obvious and their hero
work becomes an opportunity to resume
flirtation it's much less convenient
that Jane has cancer the audience knows
long before Thor as does Valkyrie it
seems Jane wants to enjoy her time as
mighty Thor and her time with Thor
Odin's son as much as possible without
bringing the sad news of Her diagnosis
into the mix but as the former couple
gets cozy again in the goat Boat
watching space dolphins on their way to
the shadow realm Jane finally blurts out
the truth Valkyrie interrupts their
first kiss in well eight years seven
months and six days
but there isn't time to worry about what
the future holds those kids need to be
rescued and Gore needs to be stopped
Jane and Thor hold on to hope that she
might be able to live cancer-free as
mighty Thor however during the three
against one melee gorsis that she's
dying even with her restorative Viking
strength she looks rough as she takes
damage during the battle in which Gore
ends up with possession of Stormbreaker
and both she and Thor begin to face the
reality of a more tragic outcome
we learn more about how Jane became
Mighty Thor and how mjolnir is affecting
her health or lack thereof as the film
progresses Darcy suggests since modern
medicine is failing her that it might be
time to turn to Asgardian magic for a
cure Dr Eric Selvig confirms Darcy's
fears through video chat that indeed her
cancer isn't responding to treatment
that's when Jane feels compelled to
journey to new Asgard and to attempt to
call the shattered Hammer into her grip
it works and the next time we see Jane
she's been transformed into mighty Thor
the film doesn't make you wonder for
very long about how this could happen in
a montage that retraces the Arc of Thor
and Jane's relationship we see that Thor
once charged mjolnir with protecting
Jane the love of his life the hammer
took this as an oath but this magical
binding pact isn't perfect and it isn't
a real solution to keeping her alive
after the fight in the shadow realm in
her human form again she lands in a
hospital bed it doesn't look like she
has much time left Thor reasons that the
effort the Mortal must use to wield
mjolnir exacts a heavy price much the
same way the necrosword both gives and
takes power from Gore the story of
Jane's cancer first appeared in Marvel
Comics and those issues go into more
detail about how mjolnir interacts with
Jane's disease though the film doesn't
get into the nitty-gritty of how the
hammer isn't saving her life in the
comics the weapon expels any toxic
substances from her body every time she
transforms into Thor but that also
includes her chemotherapy treatments
that's obviously not the case in the
film as the chemo isn't working for Jane
rather this plot Point ties into one of
the main themes of the movie Power can
have a heavy price
Thor leaves an ailing Jane to retrieve
the kidnapped Asgardian children and to
try and keep Gore from getting on the
other side of eternity's gate in an
earlier scene with the Guardians of the
Galaxy Thor all but single-handedly
saved the day much to the annoyance of
his supposed teammates but Thor gets a
little wiser with every challenge to
Stave off the black Berserkers and get
to Stormbreaker before the bifrost opens
the passageway to Eternity he'll need
actual help Thor saves the kids as
promised proving to them that Gore was
wrong some gods are looking out for the
little guy but he goes one step further
and temporarily grants them all his
abilities what follows is 100 taika ytt
and makes for one of the most
off-the-wall battles in any Marvel movie
while we've never seen Thor share his
powers before we've seen throughout the
movie that the power of Thor seems to be
shareable among many that's likely how
Jane transformed into the Mighty Thor so
why not let the kidnapped kids throw
some Thunderbolts for a while too
let's jump back to Jane's hospital room
for a second Thor has no choice but to
go after Stormbreaker since Gore will
use it to reach eternity Jane wants to
come along but he'd rather she remain in
the hospital and recuperate so they
could have a chance to be together again
when the fight is over but Jane asserts
that an even slightly prolonged life
confined to a sick bed is no life at all
with his voice trembling Thor tells her
that he loves her but he does not insist
or even ask her to stay behind as he
departs she weighs her options as if she
senses that he needs her now to help him
win the day Jane reclaims mjolnir and
joins the battle just in time to prevent
Gore from killing Thor he's grateful yet
somewhat deflated to see her materialize
he knows it means they have a chance to
defeat their enemy but it'll also likely
mean she won't survive the day once
again we see that power comes at a cost
Mighty Thor uses her last ounce of
strength to obliterate the necro sword
stripping Gore of his powers and
hastening his death but they haven't
prevented the god butcher from reaching
eternity at as he walks through the
portal Jane and Thor knowing they may
have won the battle but lost the war
share a sad but contented goodbye in
which Jane assures him she's confident
she made the right choice she feels as
though she's lived a whole second life
as Thor which isn't bad for a human
so how did Thor learn so much about the
importance of love and opening his heart
it's actually Star-Lord of all people
who has the emotional maturity to tell
Thor what he needs to hear look into the
eyes of the people that she loved
[Music]
I am
not me
Peter Quill still Mourns the loss of
Gamora but he assures Thor that it's
better to feel even if those feelings
are painful than not his advice opens
Thor to the possibility that he and Jane
could find love together again that's
why he confesses his love before he
loses her to cancer even more
significant it's also an act of Love
That Thor respects Jane's choice to have
joined him in battle even though it cost
her her life the purity of their souls
in their dying moments moves Gore he'd
been dead set on vengefully
Exterminating the gods with his victory
but he has his own change of heart Thor
reminds him that with his request of
Eternity he could bring back his beloved
daughter instead of killing the Gods in
other words he could choose love over
hate but as obvious a choice as this
might seem to most of us it comes with a
catch the necro sword has been feeding
off of Gore's anger he knows he's about
to die too and regardless of his choice
he won't be around for the repercussions
sensing good in him Jane offers that the
girl won't be alone Gore's last Act is
one of redemption and he gives his
daughter another chance at life
it's Thor's newly opened heart that
allows Thor to take on the
responsibility of parenting his former
adversary's Child Thor promises to watch
out for Gore's daughter in his absence
soon we're in Thor's kitchen where he's
making a little girl pan flaps we can
see that Thor has adopted her as his own
daughter and we learn from korg's
narration that she's called love
remember Gore referred to her as my love
throughout the film this obviously gives
the subtitle of the film a whole new
meaning and one that nobody could have
predicted or interpreted without this
piece of plot resolution All Things
Considered he's doing well as a dad and
he looks more confident instructing her
in the ways of Asgardian Warriors
Stormbreaker which played a significant
part in her Resurrection is her weapon
NOW Thor love and thunder ends with a
title card that reads Thor will return
though it doesn't say when or where we
don't know if love will join him but if
she does the fact that she's played by
Hemsworth's own daughter India rose will
help with scheduling and contracts
it's genuinely surprising to see Zeus
alive in the mid-credit Stinger since
Thor and his team talk about him as if
he's dead for the rest of the film
proper but there he is the god of
lightning complaining to someone just
off screen about his new Nemesis the God
of Thunder that someone turns out to be
Hercules played by Brett Goldstein
famous for his role as Roy Kent on Ted
lasso he's outfitted in well not much
really some chest straps a gold crown
and a sword and he looks pretty jazzed
about the chance to go after Thor for
his daddy there have been no official
announcements about any upcoming MCU
projects in which Goldstein will star
but as the MCU has been heading in a
decidedly mythological direction as of
late between eternals and Moon Knight
the character's introduction at this
juncture makes sense a Hercules based on
the one from Greek and Roman mythology
has been appearing in Marvel Comics
since 1965's journey into mystery annual
number one in which herc fights Thor in
an interesting twist over the last
several years the mcu's Thor has evolved
into the boastful jovial kind of
character that Hercules has so often
been depicted as in the comics which
presents the question how will the mcu's
Hercules carve out his own Godly Niche
hopefully we'll find out sooner rather
than later
if the mid-credit Stingers set up new
conflicts the end credit scene puts some
to rest Heimdall the Asgardian Warrior
and protector of the bifrost was slain
by Thanos early on in Avengers Infinity
War since he fought bravely as a viking
and perished in battle we could safely
assume he ascended to the paradise of
Valhalla audiences recently got a peek
at another version of the afterlife in
Moon Knight when Oscar Isaac's Mark
Spector and Steven Grant died for a
while their brief visit came with the
explanation that there are many versions
of what we might call Heavens in the
universe and Multiverse the field of
reads is one as Guardians Valhalla is
another Thor love and thunder shows us
the mcu's Valhalla for the first time
when Jane who had passed away in Thor's
Embrace only moments before arrives at
its entrance waiting for her is Heimdall
to tell her that the Asgardian version
of the afterlife is now her Eternal
reward the film ends as Jane Smiles at
the breathtakingly beautiful landscape
that stands before her this scene could
well be a last goodbye to the tooth orca
characters but since there are stories
that take place in Valhalla and Marvel
Comics we shouldn't consider Jane or
Heimdall to be permanently gone from the
MCU just yet check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more Looper
videos about the Marvel Cinematic
Universe are coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and hit the Bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]